well the last 24 hours have been some of
the most consequential that we have had
in months we first heard from the
current uh attorney general
merrick garland that no one is above the
law that he is open to prosecuting
former president donald trump
but then in addition to that we learned
based on a very interesting report from
the washington post that donald trump is
currently under criminal investigation
by the justice department this was the
question
is the justice department criminally
investigating donald trump have they
paid attention to the january 6
committee or to what's going on in
georgia or to whatever else and done
their own investigation and determined
this is worthy not necessarily of
charges but of criminal investigation
and the news that broke over the last 24
hours is that the answer is yes
we're going to look at both of these
things i was going to lead with garland
but garland being open to prosecuting
trump is irrelevant if there's no probe
it now has been uh revealed that there
is indeed a probe washington post report
justice department investigating trump's
actions in january
sixth criminal probe people familiar
with the probe said investigators are
examining the former president's
conversations and have seized the phone
records of top aides understand
this is already historic it is not
typical that a president leaves office
and then is under federal criminal
investigation now it may go to absolute
nothing the this investigation may end
up in the toilet
uh flushed 10 to 15 times but this is
already an unprecedented and unique
situation the justice department is
investigating trump's actions as part of
its criminal probe of efforts to
overturn the 2020 election according to
four people familiar with the matter
prosecutors who were questioning
witnesses before a grand jury including
two top aides to vice president pence
have asked in recent days about
conversations with trump his lawyers and
others in his inner circle who sought to
substitute trump allies for certified
electors from some states joe biden won
this is the fake elector scam
um
the prosecutors have asked hours of
detailed questions about meetings trump
led in december of 2020 and january 2021
his pressure campaign on pence to
overturn the election and what
instructions trump gave his lawyers and
advisers about fake electors and sending
electors back to the states the people
said some of the questions focused
directly on trump's on the extent of
trump's involvement in the fake elector
effort led by his outside lawyers
including john eastman and rudy giuliani
this is major folks and it appears that
a lot of the focus is on the fake
elector scheme
the belief among some legal experts is
that that's probably the easiest one to
prove
but it is all very much related
generally to trump's attempt to
overthrow the government and to install
himself the guy who did not win the
illegitimate
wouldn't even to say an illegitimate
president he just wouldn't he wasn't the
president he didn't win
um the article goes on to say
justice department investigators in
april received phone records of key
officials and aides in the trump
administration including mark meadows as
chief of staff
that effort is another indicator of how
expansive the january 6 probe had become
well before
the hearings in june and july this is
another really important question
or answer i guess we would better say
we were wondering
not only is slash was there a probe
but
did the probe only start because of the
january 6 committee hearings and it
appears that the answer is no there was
actually a criminal probe of trump that
started well before that um
what do we know about some of the
build-up to all of this well jacqueline
alemany who
works for the washington post and was
part of breaking this story appeared on
msnbc and talked about it listen to this
that's exactly right willie we've
reported that prosecutors who have
recently brought in people like greg
jacobs and and mark short
and potentially more we just
you know people were not we might not be
aware of just yet but people who were
very close to mike pence had first-hand
accounts and were witness to the
pressure campaign being applied on him
to overturn the results of the election
and we're also in the room for other
meetings involving some of the
constitutional schemes being put forth
by trump allies people like john eastman
before the president they were asked
about those interactions they were asked
about meetings in december of 2021 and
january of 2020
in december of 2020 and january of 2021
we also know that they were asked
specifically about the pressure being
put on mike pence according to
sources
and we also know that these phone
records that have been newly reported
and obtained by the justice department
included phone records from
top trump aides and mark meadows as well
someone else who was also in the room
for a lot of these uh really
explosive uh and
meetings that have recently garnered a
lot of scrutiny by all right so the
point here that i can only make uh a
limited number of times in an hour
program but i think needs to be made is
we all have been
some degree desensitized by these last
many years
uh and i include myself in that
but this is not normal this is
extraordinary these are extraordinary
times that we are living in the former
president is under criminal
investigation by the following
administration's justice department now
what could be the possible crimes i've
been reading up on this this morning as
a non-lawyer who spoke to some lawyers
there are three possibilities the
easiest to prove would likely be
conspiracy to defraud the united states
this would be over the fake electors
sending fake electors would be
committing a fraud as trump says on the
on the united states other possible
crimes obstruction of an official
proceeding now there are lots of
variations of this
but
um the one being looked at by the
january 6th committee um seems to be
1512 c which theoretically carries up to
20 years in prison i don't expect that
that's ever going to be trump's future
uh partially because he won't live 20
years and then also seditious conspiracy
is possible but again when we anything
with the word sedition in it
the bar to prove criminal intent is a
difficult one to overcome and it's sort
of related to why i know i've said this
before you don't often see perjury
charges even though people do lie in
court all the time um and we will just
have to follow it and see now if you
weren't sure about the consequential
nature of the midterm election in 2022
and of course the presidential in 2024
if you did think that those elections
were important before
they are absolutely above and beyond
important now trump got away
two different impeachments without
conviction because republicans had the
senate
you
have to understand that if control goes
back to republicans in 2022
a lot of this stuff is completely dead
in the water now might charges be
brought against trump before that maybe
i don't think so i don't know but i
would expect donald trump to announce
his candidacy very soon he believes that
that would be a way to shield himself
from the criminal probe
now if you want me to be honest if i
look at my crystal ball
i expect that even if there is such an
investigation at some point we will hear
there is really no precedent for
charging a former president of the
united states i know i'm being
pessimistic but that's my crystal ball
but uh the next question becomes
would trump announcing his candidacy do
anything to shield him here and merit
garland says the answer is no
one of our long time sponsors splendid
spoon is giving you 50 dollars off as
many of you know i am not vegetarian but
i think eating plant-based
is a great thing and i do more of it
consciously
splendid spoon takes the work out of
eating plant-based by delivering
ready-to-eat plant-based meals smoothies
and juices right to your door splendid
spoon fits into my day easily the meals
are in my fridge put them on the
stovetop or in the microwave and i've
got a great fresh plant-based meal in a
few minutes it saves me time which is
really useful right now whether you're
vegan or you just want to add an easy
delicious way to have more plants in
your diet splendid spoon is a great way
to go
there are great dishes like creamy
mushroom and spinach noodles coconut
curry cauliflower tikka soup that's one
of my favorites tons of choices the menu
rotates constantly i've tried a lot of
different meal subscription services
splendid spoon is great on both taste
and quality they pack so much flavor
into the dishes they taste freshly
cooked splendid spoons smoothies are
awesome when i'm on the go and you'll
get fifty dollars off your first week
when you subscribe at splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below